hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to hidden folks now this
game is delightfully made it's
artistically styled and it involves
finding hidden folks I think I see the
Explorer hey-oh
so it's just a it's a really delightful
game so see if you can play along it's
like Dora the Explorer push ok that's a
snack oh I'm sorry
are you dead Kiki the monkey I'm like
Kiki oh boy oh there's the rope oh it's
a big snake I thought that was a rope ah
my bad oh I'm sorry I almost cut your
head off
this game is goddamn delightful what am
I looking for a banana only the only
ripe white banana is pretty much up for
grabs
ah ok up for grabs you say it's because
this one's holding it the douchey thing
would be to hide it
ha beetle oh my god okay I got to find
this banana though the douchey thing
would be to hide it out into the white
of just the background and then I'd just
be there fending for myself just
clicking random - are we done
wait oh it's in the dog on the big dumb
goofy
why wouldn't I think that it was in the
giant bunch of bananas at the top of the
tree how dumb do I have to be that I
don't think to look at the bananas when
I'm looking for a banana oh whatever
alright it's going to the jungle oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] it's like Where's Waldo
okay everybody at home see if you can
find something here because I sure as
[ __ ] ain't gonna find it alright for
this man in distress the uncomfortable
seat is the least of his troubles
uncomfortable seat so he's sitting on a
snake or he's sitting on the teeth of a
crocodile he's
sitting on the fire he's sitting on the
pointy end of his spear uh he had a bad
night of pegging and it just didn't go
well for him that one
no you classy Jesse hey Jesse I don't
know what makes you classy mmm woman
with a guitar Oh
reptile all right you know occasionally
you come across games like this I mean
this this one in like doughnut County it
they're just freaking - oh god there's
more this is so goddamn delightful look
at this you know how much love this game
was probably made with a heaping a
heaping of love almost too much love
like a disgusting amount of love you
know that you seem to have been mobbed
by birds or you in the middle of a bird
orgy I'm not sure which one would be
more concerning but I'm gonna move on
now
okay who's sitting uncomfortably who's
an uncomfy sit I'm gonna make some smoke
rings who's sitting on comfy whoa hair
bouncing x' is you a flying monkey is
your okay whatever oh oh oh oh secret
secret butt holes in the trees of the
forest well that's always comforting to
see oh man now it's getting annoying I
gotta admit now it's not it's a lot now
I open to many buttholes and I deeply
regret it me too buddy me too it's how I
feel every day oh [ __ ] panda oh wait no
I'm not done I haven't found the
uncomfortable sitting man where's mr.
uncomfy oh there's ah no related to Bono
I suppose is that a woman is that a
naked woman I think I see Boo Boo's but
I'm not 100% sure
oh is more butt holes over here hey Andy
you bought holes want to be opened
you know under mine shouldn't I you know
it's when my brain realizes that I
shouldn't talk about gaping butt holes
on a game as delightful as this I should
probably just
that thought and that's not me saying
that thought that's me acknowledging
that that thought happened but ignoring
that thought so I'm gonna like be gone
thought get out of my head I don't know
where the [ __ ] this guy is and I don't
know how I'm gonna find these individual
Boyd's
I mean they're all the birds look like
all the other birds
okay this chicken was a single
bite-sized dinner Sammy is already Oh
King Kiki yeah I guess I'm gonna move on
I ain't got all the time in the world as
nice as this place is I gotta get go we
oh help that walkin folk get across how
how do I do that how do I do that
poop on his head okay were you gonna
poop on his head oh you were gonna poop
on his head what about these buttholes
oh these these are frown and well
butthole alert you moving guy there's
some frowny wants snake oh yeah okay I'm
watching all of you butthole all right
yeah you better not be brushing your
hair over there oh yeah I bet he would
have been at oh you almost got snaked
get out of there Birds hey lady
hey listen lady listen this guy's got an
important job to do you better get the
heck out of his way you know it's funny
the DLC for this game it was selling all
the sounds in the game and I didn't know
why they would do that at first but now
I know 100% that is the greatest idea
they've ever had in their life snake get
out of here snake what about though I
all right okay all right okay all right
okay I don't see any other threats
everything seems to be Gucci I've
clicked as much as I can clack
please tell me you doesn't have to go
anywhere else please stop right there
sir
sir stop right there there's an iguana
that iguana looks positively lethal I
think he's wearing sunglasses run away
oh never mind that I guess you're done
you figured it out the backyard
campground why did you want to go there
of all the places that you could have
gone why would you go all the way over
there bring it ten okay all right bring
a tent that's what I'll do oh oh
the guitar is having a real good
conversation with the swing what that
was easy okay all right find the dancing
man he Aiden there's eight
ella is testing her airbed zip Hey hey
Ella hey there you are okay who's in
here
Oh very naked nice nip nops I don't
think I can show that on YouTube hello
little mouse with filthy hands the
bullies quickly returned to the campfire
ello will never find her hairbrush wah
hah hah hah hah hah hah
I don't think that's a guitar Oh wah wah
wah oh oh that's a hairbrush I thought
it was a dead rat okay anyway goodbye
I'm gonna go on now
holy [ __ ] oh my god
beekeeper berry beekeeper Barry what's
nothing but beehives over here beekeeper
Barry there you said you Barry Barry can
i zoom in I can beekeeper Barry there
you are
aye beekeeper Barry how are you doing my
releases every butterfly she catches
that's why there's still so many of them
out there well ain't that just good for
her but she needs to reduce the
catastrophic population of these goddamn
butterflies alright everybody be on the
lookout for anyone looking ridiculous
oh there's lumberjack Fleck and there's
your axe eye is that Pikachu just okay
just when pica thought he could escape
the crazies it turns out he put his tent
next to the only Wi-Fi point in the
playground all bunnies are you gonna go
there they go I don't know where they're
all I see all right hello
don't mind me invading your privacy like
that hate that that's not right in any
way shape or form oh that's a lot of
tents to peekaboo in all right I almost
died I almost died I've uh I almost died
my leg got caught in a wire and I almost
died anyway let me invade the private
with a good old game of peekaboo looking
for a pika peekaboo
peekaboo peekaboo ah there you are oh
just a bad case of indigestion or
Pikachu's giving birth in that tent over
there alright there's a bad thing
monster my watches society from a
difference what would it be to be like
one of oh my god oh my god
the sun is shining too brightly today
even for classy Jessi didn't we see
didn't we see classy Jessi before oh
that sounds lousy Jessi
alright where's this goddamn there you
are you stupid my from a distance you
say from a wait a minute
around you monster mow the banana was
parked into a fruit basket at the
parking lot some kind of parking lot is
there a parking lot around here parking
lot
Oh banana there we go okay easy enough
the truffle is about to be discovered by
a hog wow thanks for being specific what
hog
uh I guess truffles are found in like
the woods but I don't know where there'd
be a hog together with her bunny friends
black Biddy hides in a hole chewing on
some snatched wheat hey black Biddy whoa
black Biddy
family a wool black Biddy ah Oh Black
Betty Black Betty Black Betty the bunny
oh wait a minute
oh he's there's a sombrero he's in one
of those things all right what else we
got tortoise Ruffalo dries in the Sun
he's in here somewhere he's somewhere in
this Beach section
he's somewhere here I can feel him I can
smell him I know he's around here
somewhere he can't run away from me
forever I know he's here I shall find
him and I shall kill him and everything
shall be I [ __ ] where is he
I mean poop where the poop is he where's
his poop Raphael Raphael Raphael oh la
fellow Raphael
get your ass out here where are you well
even I'm dumb and I can't see where it
is or you're all dumb and I'm not dumb
that's the only two options that can
come out of this and I'm pretty sure I
covered the one that it's not so that
only leaves the one that it is which is
that I'm not dumb Oh what that looks
like a toy doll oh it's a beetle okay
never mind then well this is the only
peachy place and there's nothing
happening with no titles so I got a swim
that the toy Delaine here because if the
toy Delaine here then I'm out of luck
okay what else we got the spider has a
particular taste for fungus flies okay
well that's probably over where the mush
is which would be like we're a swamp or
something right right here yeah no yeah
no no you peon European brought pins
somewhere over the rainbow way up high
there's a pig that I've heard of
snuffling a flutterby man I'm gonna RAM
swords in my eyes I can't find this
thing nothing all right well that was
pointless
oh you know I'm having more fun than you
[ __ ] ever could you don't know how
to enjoy life why do I gotta show you
how pig pig pig okay so that's there in
that whoosh oh [ __ ] I'm sorry
okay so there's got to be definitely
definitely definitely got to be
something in one of these tents right
what do I need lazy lazy well this is
gonna be a big-ass waste of time in it
you're sleeping under your sleeping bag
this is a bug there's another beetle I
don't care about that
where's the goddamn spider oh wait look
for a spiderweb I've seen spiderweb
before so if I can find spider yes and
there you have it do some farming that's
exactly what I want it all hey all right
farmer why it takes this job sweet
supervisor very seriously
all right thank you farming hey all hey
yo how you doing hey are you doing
pitchfork versus hey zero to one so you
lost so you're under one eye there you
are hey if you water your crops well and
give them a little bit extra attention
you may see this rare flower really okay
keep going keep going really water it
good alright whatever can I get some Sun
in ears there's some Sun I can turn on I
got a click them oh I had no idea oh
that's so pretty oh I found them all
more farming you know I love [ __ ] I hate
it oh this game is so cool this game has
got damn delightful ancient Native
American spirits suddenly possessed
Forester alway on oh that's not good oh
hello if you're not something then
you're real weird I guess okay there you
are oh why do you have oh oh that's
moderately concerning all that [ __ ] oh
that's that's definitely a problem
alright well thank you for that bling I
don't know why there was a beehive
buried in the ground something about
that just rubs me fundamentally wrong
but okay I guess I shouldn't ask any
questions about it and you're dead and
I'm sorry I did cause a lot of death
that way time to get some fruity fruit
physics on Newton's head okay so I need
to give someone a concussion that's what
I heard
doesn't really matter how I just got to
do it so let's make it happen
one of these apples these apples are
going down the harvest is ruined this
year there you go and he's brain damaged
okay thank you
according to Harry invisible cattle are
also cattle well according to me Harry's
just a raving lunatic
okay Wow Harry way to go you have no
idea what you're talking about
needle might not be in a haystack but
she sure knows how to roll if she [ __ ]
him in the hay stack cuz a roll in the
hay as I colloquially know it
considering that I'm from Ohio and that
means something somehow that means
having sex as far as I know maybe not
hey where's the hey you yes you hey hey
hey hey where's the hay they hate wolfy
oh [ __ ] oh she's been crushed Oh No
oh she's very crushed where'd she where
is she oh no oh that's not good oh there
you are never mind needle hi needle how
you doing rotting fish is propelling
potential customers okay what why do I
have to take care of it where's that my
job where is it that your job why don't
why is that my job yeah whatever screw
you guys can't take care of your own
[ __ ] uh well if I have to sniff it out I
guess I will but I don't know why but
first let me look at this cow this couch
not that one fake bull Barney hi wait a
minute why is it a fake bull wait wait
why is it a fake bull not moved by his
pen maybe because he's fake and has no
feelings
oh he's not moving oh that's what you
mean by literally it's not real oh
there's another beehive in the ground
again I'm not gonna question it but okay
where's this goddamn fish all right you
know what on principle I'm not gonna
take care of your fish problem that's
your problem not my problem so you guys
deal with it on your own hi hat
scarecrow is really arrogant he only
likes wheat not crops he wants his area
to be watered and will only show himself
when his wheat is fully grown well what
a dick well screw that guy what a piece
of [ __ ] all right whatever I don't even
know what wheat looks like in this
context okay well how do I water it and
what do I water I don't even know what
I'm water wheat here we go oh yeah
that's wheat I guess know if it's wheat
god this sounds well that's a goddamn
delight that's so nice almost miss one
there did I get it all did I did I get
it all now
got to look closely at it okay they all
look like they're up and up maybe that's
not wheat maybe that's like corn or
something
maybe I'm stupid maybe I need to grow
eyes maybe I'm just an idiot maybe
chicken chick hasn't gotten too far but
at least he's free freedom chicken Chuck
are you set a penguin
oh no that's a lady I thought that was a
bang one nevermind I'm just terribly
stupid entwine chicken Chuck get back in
there I don't care if you're on
tomorrow's menu you get back in there so
I just got to find the Scarecrow
wherever he is stupid piece of poop Oh
in a weird way this game reminds me of
West of loathing but maybe that's just
because it's the simplistic style of it
but god damn this game is delightful
okay high hats scarecrow where the hell
is ya where the hell is your pee if
you're not gonna show yourself why
should I even put up with your [ __ ]
wants his area to be watered and will
only show himself when his weed is fully
grown okay well there's a well here I'm
assuming this is not the wheat then it
looks a little like weed but maybe his
wheat ain't shown cuz it not be watered
yet and I got a water it it's before I
can see it is dis to eat is distil weep
wait that looks a bit more like wheat
okay oh no that's the wrong scarecrow ah
okay that's that's just a skirt you're
not you're not the right scarecrow oh
you arrogant piece of [ __ ] oh you're not
the right one either what does that mean
that you would happen to be oh no you're
not the one right either oh you're not
off the right one but you
why me thinks that maybe this one is
maybe this one is because there's water
oh oh you stupid piece of [ __ ] oh you
stupid piece of poop ah thank you thank
you so much for that oh my god why are
you out here dude get some you have a
hole in your chest you have a hole in
your chest
oh geez well you're gonna die I can
assure you there's nothing that I can
click here that could actually help
you and your circumstance so I'm just
gonna leave it at that so that is hidden
folks thank you everybody so much for
watching this game is goddamn delightful
it is adorable there's tons more
gameplay I'm assuming the left for you
guys to see so check it out for yourself
to look at the description below thank
you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]